wonderful passer sees things and his
read alluded to grant what a talent is
getting wet turn explodes to the rim
he's not the hunted he's the hunter this
move here that's next level raft of
these big-time in particular that but no
tapped up marks Carter power and
Virginia that's where they can feast
here on the offensive glass
[Applause]
mama D underneath great pass and
finishes Ashman and division one that
habit triple-double
this year's RJ tell Duke impressive
company right there an impressive wool
list of Miele act election now rest
o'clock what a play by Hunter second
round pick of the Charlotte Hornets back
in May that's Jerome with the assist
that's his feel for the game the key
tape but pop in the middle turn draw
that D Lester that was a great close out
there hustling OD season up the lane or
the head guy back out our to roam on
time and the basket counts
look at this batch now basketball team
we can make plays and finish the mental
anguish I'm sure they've had it go
through but all positive vibes right now
stop playing the ISO ball move gotta
move gotta move hi Jim
all right flooring his team to do
something could they give up another
basket to Hunter who leads the Wahoo's
with 13
[Music]
influence he has been putter from the
wind three more for Virginia now on a
roll
goodness and they started to play great
defense late and I hate Johnson he is in
his feet every time Kyle guy catches it
three-point shot yes he delivers it they
are just locked in on guys I let it beat
them guys like this are getting free
he'll beat you though he doesn't got a
lot of guys he could beat it
hunter so talented on both ends of the
floor great athlete go play for a long
time
block by hunter you don't appreciate to
roam is hunter once again wide open
three he's got 17 in the second half
he's outscored gardner-webb alone finds
there was a lot of excitement here in
this building in the first half Johnson
back to the RAM and hunter
[Applause]